لا جديد يذكر مواجهه جديده بين ليفربول
وريال مدريد في دوري ابطال اوروبا
والنتيجه واحده الفريق الاسباني يقسوا على
الراس في ذهاب دوري السته عشر هذه المره
في عقر داره وبين جماهيره في التفاصيل نجح
حامل اللقب مدريد في تحويل تاخره بهدفين
امام ليفربول خلال اول ربع ساعه من
المباراه الى فوز عريض بنتيجه مان الى
خمسه قبل نحو 25 دقيقه من النهايه مباراه
مثيره شهدت خطاين فادحين لافضل حارسي مرمى
في العالم الاولى من تيبو كورتوا حارس
مدريد الذي اهدى هدفا لصلاح لكن الرد اتى
من اليسون بكر حارس ليفربول الذي قدم هديه
مماثله ليوفنتوس جونيور قبل صافره الشوط
الاول بهذا الفوز وضع ريال مدريد قدما في
الدوري ربع النهائي من البطوله لكنه ايضا
مغص فرحه محمد صلاح برقم القياسي الجديد
فبعد هدفه امس اصبح الهداف التاريخي
لليفربول في دوري ابطال اوروبا برصيد 42
هدفا
لقاء ريال مدريد وليفربول في ذهاب دور 16
من دوري ابطال اوروبا شهد العديد من
الارقام القياسيه نستعرض ابرزها فينيسيوس
جونيور لاعب مدريد البالغ من العمر 22
عاما هو اصغر لاعب يسجل هدفين على ملعب
ليفربول في اي منافسه اوروبيه منذ
الهولندي كرويف عام
1966 وبعدما نجح في تسجيل هدف بمباراه امس
صلاح يعادل رقم ديروبا كاكثر اللاعبين
الافارقه تسجيلا في دوري ابطال اوروبا
برصيد اربعه واربعين هدفا صلاح ايضا اصبح
اول لاعب في تاريخ دوري ابطال اوروبا
يشارك بالتسجيل وصناعه الاهداف في ثماني
مباريات مختلفه لصالح فريق انجليزي هدف
داروين نونيز بعد مرور ثلاث دقائق و10
ثواني من انطلاق اللقاء هو اسرع هدف يسجله
ليفربول على ملعب في تاريخ مشاركته بدوري
ابطال اوروبا واخيرا كريم بنزيما مهاجم
ريال مدريد اصبح اول من يسجل سته اهداف في
مرمى ليفربول في المسابقات الاوروبيه
بعدما احرز هدفين في لقاء امس
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا صح في الرياضيات مراد المصري
بلشنا نناقش معاك قبل الهواء طيب مراد
نبدا بالتصريحات الاخيره الملفته لساديو
ماني مهاجم بايرن ميونخ يقول فيها انه
محمد صلاح ليس هدافا والهداف السيء احسن
منه حديثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل اوفى حول
يعني ناخذها كامله او بكيفك عن طريق
السؤال او غيره هو هو كلام ممكن الهداف هو
المهاجم الهداف للعلم هو صلاح هو لاعب
جناح وليس هداف ولكنه مع اللعب سجل اهداف
كثيره واصبح يسجل يعني اعتقد انه دائما
هناك يحاولوا الاصطياد في المياه العكره
يعني اعتقد انه علاقه ماني وصلاح سيئه اي
علاقه شخصيه
هو اختار مهاجم
اللاعب البلجيكي مراد يعني كثير بالفتره
الاخيره كتير في الفتره الاخيره عم نسمع
محمد صلاح وانتقادات لمحمد صلاح هل انتهى
محمد صلاح رياضيا ام انها سحابه عابره
يعني محمد صلاح الموسم الحالي مسجل 19 هدف
لحد الان للعلم هداف دوري ابطال اوروبا
ثمان اهداف وغيرها يعني على سبيل المثال
احمد حسام ميدو اللي بنحكي عنه العالمي
راح والعالم سنوات طويله سلامات ومع
توتنهام كامله سجل 27 هدف كامله خلال موسم
كامل صلاح في اسوا موسم لاله وما زال موسم
مستمر مسجل 19 هدف هو مشكله صلاح الفريق
لانه هو صلاح بحث عن العقد الافضل وحصل
العقد الافضل هو حاليا من ضمن افضل 10
لاعبين راتب سنوي في العالم اكثر من 20
مليون دولار امريكي راتبه السنوي مبلغ ضخم
حصل ولكن ليفربول ركز على صلاح ونسي ان
يكمل الفريق
الجماعي مهم جدا نعم هذا الامر الى بدايه
اللي هو رحيل المدير الرياضي في مع نهايه
الموسم الماضي مايكل ادوارد هو الذي صنع
ليفربول في السنوات الاخيره هو الذي تعاقد
مع صلاح وماني وغيرها من الاسماء ليفربول
يحصل للمره السابعه ضد الملك ريال مدريد
وكل مره جماهير ليفربول لما تهاجم الفريق
لا تهاجم تهاجم محمد صلاح وتحمل المسؤوليه
على الفشل هل بالفعل هو من يتحمل مسؤوليه
ممكن جماهير العربيه
ما حصل امس في مباراه امس ملخص موسم
ليفربول البدايه القويه ثم الانهيار وهذا
ما حصل مع ليفربول هذا الموسم البدايه
القويه ثم الانهيار هناك يعني واضح في
فقدان لاعبي الوسط التركيبه الفريق غير
متجانسه
الرهان على نونيز مع رحيل الماني يعني
اخطاء اداريه قاتله وقع فيها ليفربول
هل اليوم محمد صلاح يعاني من معنويات
رياضيه نازله شوي بنقدر نقول يعني مثلا
الحسره الدوليه عدم المشاركه المنتخب
المصري في المونديال وايضا حتى الاتهامات
مش بس مع ليفربول حتى لما يكون يشارك مع
منتخب بلاده انه كانه الولاء ومساله
الولاءات كمان والانتماءات كان في لها دور
منتخب مصر مع صلاح تاهل كاس العالم لاول
مره من عام 1990 كان قريب من الفوز بلقب
امم افريقيا الاخيره خساره بركلات ترجيح
ايضا عدم التاهل كاس العالم مباراه فاصله
قويه كانت امام السنغال وايضا ركلات ترجيح
يعني اعتقد محمد صلاح يعني لا يخرج جهدا
مع منتخب بلاده ويقدم المطلوب منه ولكن
لانه هو الافضل حاليا دائما الافضل هو
معرض الانتقادات على سبيل المثال ميسي
ميسي سلامات طويله في الارجنتين كان هو
يتعرض للانتقادات كبيره انه انت لا تقدم
وغيرها وهذا حتى يعني دائما اللاعب النجم
يجب ان يتحمل الانتقادات
نفس المشاكل اللي عم تحكي عنها الاداريه
كانت في ريال مدريد دفعت كريستيانو لترك
المنتخب هل يمكن ان نرى صلاح هذه المره
يترك ليفربول ام ان هذا مستبعد هو الان
المشكله عند ليفربول وليس الصلاح بعد
توقيع العقد طويل الامد والراتب كما تحدث
راتب صلاح حاليا مرتفع للغايه هو كان
الصيف الماضي يجب التحديد المصير يعني انه
هل سنمدد ام سترحل لصلاح النادي راحن على
بقائه ولكن انا اعتقد انه مشكله ليفربول
انه في الوقت اللي حافز على صلاح نسي ان
يبني الفريق وليس يعني انه ليفربول
تاريخيا كان مبني على الفريق وليس نجم او
احد طيب مراد كمان اليوم كريستيانو
رونالدو ليونيل ميسي اثبتوا للعالم انه
سنين التالق هي كانت في الثلاثينات هل
اليوم الفرصه ما زالت سانحه امام محمد
صلاح لكي يزيد من هذا القلق بالطبع لانه
صلاح العمر 30 اعتقد انا كما تحدث مره
ثانيه ارقام صلاح واداؤه ليس هو المشكله
يعني
هدف وسجل هدف عاد الرقم دروجبا كافضل هداف
افريقي في تاريخ دوري ابطال اوروبا 44 هدف
لتكلم يعني برضه برشا اضرب لك مثال ميديا
سجل هدفين دوري ابطال اوروبا اللاعبين
العرب ممكن اهدافهم لا تتجاوز هذا لا تصل
الى 10 اهداف حتى هو يقدم منه ولكن لا
توجد مجموعه تسانده هو المشكله مع صلاح
حاليا فقدان المجموعه في ليفربول فقدان
الاداء الجماعي كان في نوع من انواع
الترابط في ليفربول تشعر يعني في وقت
الاوقات كان انه ما تقدر تختاري مين النجم
في ليفربول رغم تالق صلاح يعني كان صلاح
متالق وتم ترشيح فان دايك لافضل لاعب في
العالم كان صلاح متالق ماني شجره اهداف
الحاسمه هو وفرميني وتلاتي المقدمه كان
متكامل حاليا تشعر كانه كل لاعب يعني
معزول على الاخر لا تشعر بالتجانس في
ليفربول